I have not had a conversation like this with a random person and a long time.
Yay.
A viral New York Times article featured 36 questions that could supposedly make
any two people fall in love.
We want it to see what would happen if we ask these questions to two complete
strangers on a blind date.
My name,
my full name is Jack Hara,
but I only go by Kira.
I am single.
I'm excited.
I mean they go really good or really bad.
So
my name is Russell and I'm single.
Super Sangal.
Actually.
Uh,
it's still nervous.
I think like all this on all the anticipation leading up to it.
It's like making it worse.
Hello.
Hi,
how are you doing?
I'm Russell.
I'm Kara.
Kara,
nice to meet you.
I guess we're having tea.
Yeah,
these are cute.
I know,
right?
I like this set up.
I know it's very,
uh,
Zin.
Should we cheers first blind date,
right?
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well that's good.
We're doing this.
Okay.
It's going to ask,
when did you last sing to yourself and to someone else?
Um,
the last time I spoke to myself was last night cause I'm always in my room
dancing and singing,
um,
to someone else probably this morning.
What about you?
Um,
I sang to myself this morning for sure.
Getting Ready.
Okay.
Um,
that's probably a daily occurrence.
Yeah.
It's either singing or rapping a ball.
Do you have a secret hunch about how you will die?
Okay.
Oh that's creepy.
Um,
no but interesting fact when I was like 19,
I had just had like this belief that I was going to die young.
Do we re I was having Deja Vu so often.
Do you believe in Deja Vu and has an off topic?
There's no topics,
right?
They just,
who is so weird?
Cause there's like really random times.
I'm like,
I've done this before.
You know how like Mario Kart?
Uh,
the checkpoints.
Checkpoints.
Yeah.
Oh
here we go.
If you could change anything about the way you were raised,
what would it be?
Oh,
I probably would have liked to heard a little bit more.
My mom passed when I was young,
when I was like seven and I was raised by a single dad.
He was just always so busy.
Yeah.
He's a doctor.
He's a pediatrician like and yeah,
I don't want it to come off like I'm
no,
don't like this is your experience.
Yeah.
But I just don't want it to sound like I'm ungrateful or anything like that.
Like my the
best,
I wish I didn't know the details of my mom and my dad's relationship and the
details of the dysfunction because now I carry that as a woman.
But you recognize it,
right?
Yeah,
it is what it is.
Yeah.
Now I can like break the cycle,
but it's still like that's not easy.
Yeah.
Growing up sucks.
I know,
right?
Cause then you're like,
oh,
I'm really fucked up.
But then it's like,
oh wait,
everyone's really fucked up.
Complete this sentence.
I wish I had someone with whom I could share.data.
I wish I had someone with whom I can share my love for food.
Oh my gosh.
Is that it?
Are you serious?
I love to eat.
Okay.
It's over.
We're good.
All right.
Um,
I wish I had someone to share.
I'm gonna say my love for dancing in the mirror to Beyonce.
Like I have friends who like love Beyonce like me,
but it's just not the same.
Like I need my girl,
like she's not here,
so I feel,
yeah.
Okay.
Take one minute and tell your partner your life story as much detail as
possible.
Oh my gosh.
Ooh.
I'm trying to think of good stuff and bad stuff cause I don't want to bias your
story or I know.
So I was born man,
New York when I was about six years old.
I witnessed my dad
become physically violent towards my mom.
Maybe about a few months after we ended up moving and that was the start of
moving all the time.
I went to Buffalo State College in my last year.
I was like,
you know what,
I've outgrown this place.
I don't feel like it's given me anything.
Um,
I was actually like depressed that just wasn't happy.
And then I decided to move to California and I moved here by myself with very
little money.
But I have a lot of faith and I believe that if you really want something it's
because you're supposed to have it.
So I just,
we just did it and now I'm here.
I have so much respect for.
Wow.
Thank you.
Real.
Yeah,
thank you.
Definitely that's inspiring.
So I lived in the same house my entire life up until college.
I always wanted that.
I did everything my older brother did.
He started rapping,
so I was like,
I'm going to start rapping too.
Is he annoyed by lies?
Like dude,
I got into acting on my own though.
I brought it up to my house.
I think I'm going to major in acting.
He's like,
are you sure?
And I was like,
okay,
so have like this identity crisis with like career and passions and stuff like
that.
My family is like super mixed too.
So I had like that identity crisis thing were black,
white and Japanese.
Oh Wow.
My Dad is all three.
Wow.
Yeah.
And then my mom was black and white.
That's so interesting.
Well,
which part?
All of it.
Like that's so many different like cultures makes them one.
I just turned 30 it's,
yeah,
I think that might be the Asian part of you.
I'll take it.
Whatever it is.
Black don't crack all of the amazing skin.
Well,
so I see people nodding.
That's true.
Anyways,
I just turned 30 so that was like a really big,
I was like,
are you,
what are you doing right?
Are you really gonna gonna do what you say you've been trying to do or are you
just gonna keep on doing this stuff?
So here we are.
Okay.
Yeah.
Now it's like acting,
film making,
shifting the culture.
Didn't you put your age out there?
I'll put mines.
I'm 24 that also,
and I talked about the records show.
I did not ask alternate sharing something you consider a positive characteristic
of your partner.
You seem very honest.
Oh,
just in the way you like show up in the world.
I don't even know how to respond to that one.
I'm just going to take that one in Israel.
You're extremely brave.
Thank you for moving out here like he did.
That's true.
I just grew up like an hour away from La.
Yeah.
You know,
like the stakes are just so low for me to like come out here.
But for you I was like really big deal,
so,
oh,
thank you.
I feel like you're very confident to not in just like,
like I'm confident in myself,
but like,
I don't know if that's true.
Um,
I feel like it's becoming true.
Obviously you like to have a good time,
like the whole,
that's anything less as,
so actually don't go out that often though.
It's not even about like,
you just enjoy your time.
Uh,
I started,
you'll start.
Okay.
That's fair.
Oh,
this is good.
Okay.
Would you go on a second date with your partner?
I would totally gone and second day with you.
Yeah.
I have not had a conversation like this with a random person and a long time.
I'm flattered.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
We got to go eat somewhere.
We did it.
We do.
But like good food.
You didn't answer the question.
Would you go in a second by second?
Yes.
Yeah.
Oh,
you're right.
You're right.
You can't leave anything to his eyes.
Never ever bring her around me right now.
I was like,
yes.
And we have to go get some.
Yeah,
that's why I was saying yesterday for sure.
Okay.
As a tradition,
we should always ordered tea.
I can dig that.
That's a thing that a male too,
cause like if it's after 6:00 PM is not going to work.
Yeah.
Cool.
I'll give you a hug
if I can.
All these old names.
Let me get up here.
Hey guys,
this is Jason from jubilee.
We hope you enjoyed that blind date.
I know I did.
I feel like there's a chance at this one.
Do you feel it?
It might be something.
Um,
as always,
please make sure you click here to watch more videos.
Click here to subscribe and we will see you next time.
Okay.